lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
pensar en lo que pasa cuando definimos
una función y también lo que pasa cuando
revisamos paso a paso un programa y
usamos funciones así que digamos que
escribimos este programa que revisamos
el vídeo anterior y lo corremos el
intérprete empieza en esta primera línea
y dice miren es la definición de una
función aquí donde definimos la función
factorial y lo que quiero hacer es
dibujar un cuadro grande un cuadro
grande naranja que es el ambiente o
entorno del programa y aquí estarán
todas las definiciones y variables y
todo lo que el programa necesita o sea
el contexto en el que el programa está
ocurriendo entonces inmediatamente el
programa asocia el nombre factorial con
esta función que tenemos aquí asocia la
palabra factorial con esta función la
etiqueta factorial con la función que
tenemos aquí definida con todo este
código así que pasamos un número
le pasamos un número a la función bueno
dejen escribir esto un poco diferente
esta es una función ustedes verían una
anotación diferente si estuviéramos en
una clase formal de computación pero lo
que estoy diciendo es que factorial se
refiere a una función que tiene
parámetros parámetros mejor dicho el
parámetro número
el parámetro de esta función es número
entonces si le damos a la función el
parámetro número la función podrá
procesar el código que tenemos aquí
arriba así que déjenme copiar déjenme
copiar y pegar el código lo voy a tratar
de copiar y pegar esto copio y pego para
tener todo en el contexto del programa y
el ambiente o entorno del programa
incluye todo esto nuestro cuadro debe
abarcar todo esto todo este código que
estamos copiando y pegando para no tener
confusión el cuadro naranja debe abarcar
todo esto entonces los parámetros bueno
mejor dicho el parámetro es número y el
cuadro naranja debe abarcar todo esto ok
estas primeras líneas dicen que en
nuestro entorno hay una definición de
una función factorial que tiene un
parámetro que es el parámetro número que
ejecuta este código y regresa el
resultado en la variable producto
devuelve el valor del producto
recorriendo línea por línea hasta que
llega a esta instrucción que tenemos
aquí y que dice que esta variable
entrada del usuario va a ser igual a lo
que le regrese a esta función input
llamamos esta función input y le pasa el
resultado a la variable entrada del
usuario y aquí vemos la terminología que
hemos estado manejando la función input
pasa un string y una vez más la palabra
string suena como algo fantástico pero
literalmente significa una cadena de
caracteres como ya lo hemos visto le
pasa el texto que tenemos aquí teclea un
número entero no negativo para calcular
el factorial aún los espacios son parte
del string y sabemos que es un string
porque está entre comillas cualquier
tipo de comillas dobles o sencillas así
que pasamos este string a la función
input y el prompt que usa este string
lee un número o lo que el usuario teclea
lo evalúa y luego lo almacena en la
variable entrada del usuario
bueno debería decir en el contexto de
payton que hace que la variable entrada
del usuario apunte hacia el valor que el
usuario teclea así que si el usuario
teclea un 3
la variable entrada del usuario
entrada de él
usuario ahora se va a referir en este
entorno global del programa factorial se
refiere a una función y entrada del
usuario se refiere a lo que el usuario
teclea y en este ejemplo específico se
refiere al 3 y entonces vamos a la
siguiente línea que dice ok factorial de
la entrada del usuario hace que esta
variable se refiera a lo que sea que
obtengamos cuando llamamos a la función
factorial de la entrada del usuario de
esta variable que tenemos aquí de esta
entrada del usuario y esta es la parte
interesante en este punto del programa
el factorial de la entrada del usuario
esta parte que tenemos aquí hará una
llamada a la función factorial a esta
función y pasa el argumento de lo que el
usuario teclea el argumento es igual a
lo que el usuario teclea es igual a la
entrada del usuario y entrada del
usuario está apuntando a 3 en nuestro
ejemplo así que le va a pasar el 3 a la
función factorial y en el mundo de esta
función o sea dentro del contexto de la
función en él
en el que estamos en este contexto en el
que estamos ahora digamos que este es el
ambiente o entorno de la función lo voy
a marcar con un cuadro verde con un
cuadro verde
la variable número estamos en el mundo
de la función factorial la variable
número ahora hace referencia a este 3 y
ahora quiero ser muy cuidadosa porque
estamos empezando a hablar del alcance
de las variables ahora tocaremos esta
idea del alcance de las variables
la variable número está en el contexto
de esta función y sólo la podemos usar
dentro de la función no lo podemos usar
fuera si escribiremos por acá fuera de
esta función imprime el número print en
número
obtendremos un error esto marcaría un
error porque esta variable es parámetro
de la función factorial y solo puede ser
usada dentro de la función factorial el
alcance de esta variable número es solo
aquí dentro de la función el lugar donde
podemos hacer referencia esta variable
es solamente dentro de esta función
así que obtenemos esta variable en
números y luego se ejecuta este código
aquí producto ahora se refiere a uno
la variable producto es igual a 1
producto es igual a 1 y continuamos con
la ejecución del código y aquí tenemos
otro ejemplo del alcance de las
variables esta variable y sólo se puede
usar dentro del ciclo for si
escribiéramos return y marcaría error y
pasaremos por este código varias veces
cuando i sea igual a cero cuando y sea
igual a 1 cuando y sea igualados y todas
las veces hasta que y sea igual a número
menos 1 y se irá incrementando 1 cada
vez y esta expresión de aquí y más 1
será evaluada empezando por 1 luego 2
luego 3 hasta que esta expresión sea
igual a número y cada vez obtendremos un
nuevo producto que será igual al
producto anterior por esta expresión y
más 1
y al final cuando hayamos terminado con
la ejecución de este ciclo ford la
variable producto va a tener el factor y
al de número factorial de número
este producto va a tener el factor y'all
de número
entonces mientras se ejecuta este código
de la función factorial producto va a
tener un montón de valores primero
valdrá 1 luego 2 luego 6 que es igual a
3 por 2 y entonces vemos que
eventualmente producto va a apuntar a 6
se va a referir a este 6 y este valor es
devuelto se regresa y cuando digo que se
regresa es que terminamos de evaluar
toda esta cosa que tenemos aquí y el
resultado será 6 y cuando sale de este
programa le dice el intérprete que el
factorial de la entrada del usuario le
dice que el factorial de la entrada
del usuario ahora va a apuntar al 6
bueno creo que tal vez estarán un poco
confundidos con todo este diagrama pero
lo que quieres que entiendan lo que está
pasando realmente otra vez
entrada del usuario se está refiriendo a
una cosa le pasa a esa cosa la función
factorial al programa de la función y
nos vamos a esta parte de aquí y dentro
de la función factorial del programa de
factorial pasamos este valor de entrada
del usuario que nuestro ejemplo es 3 así
que dentro del programa factorial número
va a apuntar a 3
la variable número se va a referir a 3 y
corremos este código con número igual a
3 y al final va a devolver producto que
será el factor y'all de número así que
esta simple instrucción evalúa el
factorial de cualquier cosa que le
pasemos aquí y en este caso el factorial
de 3 y entonces el factorial de la
entrada del usuario ahora se va a
referir a esto porque aquí se lo estamos
asignando y luego lo imprimimos
imprimimos el valor de factorial
espero que esto no los haya confundido
mucho en el siguiente vídeo discutiremos
la posibilidad de hacer cosas
interesantes con esta función factorial